i've talked to like i talked to a lot of
people and i've been on some i've talked
to some i wouldn't even say conservative
men more like the red pill community men
where they're like women's you know
women stay home and i know a lot of
women who actually like enjoy my best
friend having the time of her life with
little kid my sister-in-law same thing
she just had a little baby she's having
the time of her life although she works
as well but like
and then
me and i think it's my and i honestly
think it's my personality
because i'm driven in a way that i know
a lot of my friends aren't uh if i
change like when i have more kids
because i would really like more kids if
i
stayed home and didn't work i would go
crazy and it would be not good for
anybody
like i i'm not able to do it and i've
figured out that i'm able to have a kid
spend really quality time with that kid
it's different when they're really
little like if they're under a year old
they're kind of glued to you and that's
that
but after that i think depending on what
type of woman you are there is a way to
balance it so that you're able to work
and fulfill one side of yourself that
maybe not everybody has and also have
kids and i think
i think it's important to talk about
because i think a lot of women don't
have kids a lot of women who are more
driven don't have children because
they're like well
i'm not going to be able to to do it
right and i think that that's just a lie
that there is a way to do both it's
tricky and it's gonna be trickier i
think for a woman than for man because
you're female that's just like how the
world is but i think it's doable
it's good that you guys have talked
about that
yeah i think that
if you're gonna do both you will have to
end up sacrificing parts of each that's
just obviously you only have a finite
amount of time every single day you have
to sacrifice a part of each i mean i
know plenty of women who are
conservative and they they also have
jobs and and also provide for their kids
and you can see some of them have
sacrificed their kids for their career
and the things that they're doing and
it's like if that's if that's what you
want to do i i guess i get it but you
know throughout history i mean
there have been women who have gone to
work throughout history this isn't just
a totally nuanced thing where where
women have stayed home forever but i
think that
i think that women
should be prioritizing kids over the
career if you're saying that you are
splitting it up and saying okay i'm
going to do 50 50. that is only 50 of
the time that your kid is getting with
you and i think that
studies show in in basically every
category that if you want to have good
kids with good values so you should
spend more time with them and that's
also a dad thing that's also a dad thing
dad should come home from work and at
least spend time with their kids not
just go up and go to sleep or watch tv
so it's a it's a tied together thing
both of them have to to put in the work
for their kids i mean this is why i talk
to so many parents uh conservative
parents who say yeah my kids now they're
horrible leftists they're communist
socialists they shave their head or
whatever and i'm like yeah that's partly
your fault that's your fault for not
taking enough interest in your child you
didn't have dinner with them you didn't
sit down and talk to them by your values
you didn't take them to church it's your
fault if you want them to be good you
make them good yourself
yeah and be careful about what school
you put them in right if you're like oh
i don't like what that school's teaching
my kids i don't like their teacher
that teacher is teaching your kids for
like what is it
nine to three
five days a week
and you don't you don't like that
and you literally have an option here
it's like oh no it's the closest school
and i don't have enough money so it
needs to be a public school find a
different one although to be fair public
schools it's tricky like you said it's
very tricky so
there's a pro there's actually a massive
problem there and not everybody can
homeschool so no it's tricky but i mean
i
and i didn't grow up now nowadays it's
worse but i remember my dad took me out
of class
i don't even remember why because i was
little i was in grade like two three and
four and be like oh you're staying home
this week like why am i staying home
this week but like sweet i'm staying
home this week and i later found out
those were the more like the politically
correct weeks where
guest speakers would come in and teach
you about
i think it was i think it was mostly
like relationships
in a politically correct way and my dad
like from early ages was like nah
staying home this week like so there i
feel like there are kind of things you
can dodge although it's pretty
intertwined in how people are schooled
now so maybe maybe i'm not being
sympathetic enough to people but i feel
like if you have a strong like
if you're at home and you talk to your
kids and you have dinner and you explain
these things and you say yeah you know
some of the things you're gonna be
taught aren't true
i've already told scarlett that when she
comes home and she's like is this true
i'm like no well so-and-so said it was
true well people lie
yeah you have to think yeah
the kids aren't gonna know anything that
isn't told to them
and so i i just find it funny that all
these people come and talk about
indoctrination and they say oh you wanna
homeschool your kids or you want to make
your kid a christian you want to
indoctrinate them with those values and
it's like
in a way yes i mean not indoctrinate but
i want to i want to give my kids these
values i don't care about what you think
about me leftists i want to push these
values push these values on my kids to
make them good people and then if you if
you send them to public school then
they're just indoctrinated by the
government so would i rather have them
be indoctrinated by me or indoctrinated
by
you teacher who has a transition closet
it seems pretty obvious but they don't
want you to have
i mean there are many people on the left
who don't want you to even have
ownership of your kids some of these
radical wing of the la they want to say
oh the government basically owns your
kids you send them to school the parents
don't get any say and now you're our kid
that's nuts how that's got to be like
it's that that transition closet you
mentioned like i know that there are
these tick tocks that go viral that show
some of these awful things but how
frequent do you think that kind of thing
is like that's got to be more on the
rare side don't you think
yeah of course i mean i mean you know
the
you hear something like that and it's
obviously this isn't in every single
classroom there's no doubt that that's
this is a instance that has been
showcased and it's blowing up on social
media and people are
amplifying it but what you will see is
that there are so many examples of
people who want this taught i mean when
you look at the polling when you look at
all these pictures of teachers when you
look at the amount of people who got mad
at the don't say gay bill in florida
there's plenty of people who are for
this leftist agenda in the schools not
all of them are as radical not all of
them are are coming out to their kids as
they are and and trying to push them
into some ideology some of them just are
teaching a little bit better of course
but there are there are many people and
if you think about it
there let's say that transition closet
is just in one classroom well that's
still one person's kid that's still one
person's kid that could be getting
indoctrinated or being groomed by a
teacher in many places i think these are
sexual predators i think that it just
needs to be banned nationwide this type
of this type of behavior this type of
education because it's it's not for
children and it's it's ruining some kids
lives
yeah 100 i'm 100 with you like i don't
know if i'd uh i mean i'm probably
conservative i've always identified as a
libertarian never identified as a
conservative i was like no i'm like i
don't really care as long as everybody
leaves me alone i don't really care what
what goes on out there but
what's good what's going on in schools
and like hormone replacement therapy for
kids
that is completely unforgivable